rescatistas con lanchas y buzos que
barren autopistas inundadas en búsqueda
de víctimas y desaparecidos
a medida que cesan las intensas lluvias
en alemania los equipos de rescate
intensifican sus labores más que nunca
ciudades y viviendas del oeste del país
continúan inundadas en el peor desastre
natural en medio siglo el presidente
alemán frank walter steinmeier reiteró
su apoyo a los más afectados las
regiones y el gobierno federal dejaron
en claro desde muy temprano que aquellos
que han perdido tanto que han tenido
tantas pérdidas les proporcionaremos
ayuda y hasta el momento alemania
reporta más de 130 muertos y cientos de
desaparecidos en distintos sectores los
propios vecinos se han unido a las
labores de limpieza en otras el ejército
utiliza tanques para extraer agua de
viviendas y vehículos en la vecina
bélgica son más de 20 los fallecidos el
primer ministro del país alexandr dejó
junto a la presidenta de la comisión
europea
úrsula von der leyen visitó la ciudad de
roses fort asolada por las inundaciones
y he visto esto en la televisión pero
ver la angustia humana de verdad es
conmovedor y esta angustia humana no la
vemos de la misma manera en la
televisión vemos mucha solidaridad pero
sigue siendo necesaria mucha ayuda entre
tanto los servicios de emergencia de
países bajos permanecen en alerta máxima
los ríos desbordados temen fuertes
inundaciones en toda la provincia sureña
de limburg o ya es el caso de algunas
urbes como la ciudad de bell no